Caucasian that word comes to us from a
rugged land where Europe smacks into
Asia sandwiched between countries that
always grab headlined
Russia Iran Turkey but here's a headline
for you this little area is one of the
world's great linguistic hot zones a
place where the mountains are full of
languages welcome
to the Caucasus Georgia is a US state
that's about 300 miles tall with a
population over 10 million most everyone
here speaks one language English a turn
of the globe away straddling the
southeast of Europe is a country we call
Turkey and east of Turkey there's
another Georgia watch what happens when
I take Georgia and put it over Georgia
there's a lot more Georgia left it leaks
into Russia and over into Azerbaijan it
even covers part of Armenia and Turkey
all these borders between the Black Sea
and the Caspian Sea but these are
nothing compared to the number of
languages here as the Kurdish saying
goes we have no friends but the
mountains
I don't know Kurdish or the more than 50
languages of the Caucasus but Kurdish is
a distant relative of the words I'm
speaking right now it's in the Iranian
branch of our indo-european family which
is something it shares with Citians last
descended efficient you can hear echoes
of familiar words like the word for door
ditty blot in Armenia adore sounds
similar boar but Armenian is a separate
indo-european branch their unique
alphabet was created by this gentleman
scholar mr. Mashtots making Armenian one
of the rare languages in the region with
its own old writings some Armenians
claim mashed oats also taught the
Georgians how to write but Georgians beg
to differ armenian splits another
language down the middle in this
disputed turf where the name you give
and whether you call the fighting in the
90s liberation or occupation is tense
stuff this other language belongs to the
country with the world's lowest capital
nearly 100 feet 30 meters below sea
level
Azerbaijan II after all that
indo-european looks strange unless you
know Turkish the Turkic family has
multiple branches all over the Caucasus
it builds long words with glued on
endings where the vowels harmonize a lot
like Hungarian remember things aren't so
Turkic up here in Europe's only Buddhist
region this is kalmykia a Russian
Republic settled by I rats who speak a
relative of Mongolian so there's
mongolic here there's Hellenic here
Caucasus Greek there's Semitic Assyrian
neo Aramaic but there was one obvious
blob we ignored come on who brings the
big guns into this area metaphorically
speaking of course Russian in the Slavic
branch of indo-european V a couple years
ago Russia held the Winter Olympics in
the city of Sochi drama ensued what
attracted a lot of press was the
exorbitant cost but there's another
controversy you may have missed
ethnic Circassians have long considered
sochi their land taken in the 1800s when
the russian empire vowed to conquer the
caucasus and pacify or expel every
indigenous group one of the men in that
army was Leo Tolstoy this is where he
tasted war and started writing the last
speaker of Sochi zubik language died in
Turkey in 1992 with him perished the
largest consonant inventory outside of
Africa over three times as many as
English and just to be extreme only two
basic vowels ah and uh this is the kind
of special stuff that keeps language
nerds infatuated with indigenous
Caucasian languages
indigenous means something special here
see for linguists there are languages of
the Caucasus and then Caucasian
languages these smaller families born in
and limited to the Caucasus few vowels
many consonants including throaty sounds
ha ha ha English has one such sound
Arabic several no competition for these
Caucasian tongues ho and they probably
had even more in the past but the real
Caucasian hot topic came from one
example in an old grammar of Silva - Sh
there was an intransitive verb with the
subject that could resemble an object I
fell and it was my fault
like on purpose vs. fell me on accident
it sounds simple but the implications
were huge this example fell into the
right hands and the concept of argot
ivities a malingerer croc star in 1770 a
German naturalist set out on an
expedition to the Caucasus trekking with
a royal kabardian in Georgian entourage
he took notes and divided caucasian
languages into four families each one
with its own proto-language and he did
this over a decade before a well-known
speech by Sir William Jones led drew
attention to classifying into European
later there did come a one-family fits
all push to bundle them into a bureau
Caucasian the idea ultimately failed to
win converts today we count three
families north west north east south the
south cart valayan includes georgian an
indigenous language with its own ancient
literature and the reason why Joseph
Stalin a native Georgian had hot accent
patterns in his speeches so latouche
though that's in north east caucasian a
family native to the border republics of
Dagestan and Chechnya Chechen has an
oddly large number of vowels for a
Caucasian language
this line marks a republic where they
speak a Georgian dialect they're on good
terms but it's not so in these dots
where they broke away in 1992 with 13
months of ethnic strife the local
applause is part of northwest caucasian
the family of Circassian and your old
consonantal friend
Rubick this family has been blamed for
making caucasian hard to classify see
they have these roots with one measly
consonant and they do something called
head marking as a result they can lose
resemblances more quickly making it
harder to compare them and find siblings
Caucasian isn't one family is it one
area though perhaps the languages
coexisted long enough to pick up each
other's habits it's not out of the
question we saw how it happened in
Mesoamerica it's still debated if this
even fits for the Caucasus so maybe not
a language area but definitely an area
with lots of languages and you've still
got to be wondering why why so many
Joanna Nichols tells us the answer may
not be on the speaker's lips but under
their feet
geography gives some families spread
zones easy terrain for expanding other
terrains are residual zones holding
languages in place which zone is
responsible here I hope you said both
languages from the lowlands flow into
the area with then the mountains keep
them so the three Caucasian families
survived in place and didn't spread
beyond over time others passed through
and got stuck and the diversity grew we
end up with this map a map of more than
50 languages across seven families each
splash of color with its own stories to
tell
stick around and subscribe for language
[Music]
you